vous êtes nombreux à me demander souvent
comment on fait le bilan rôle dans le
studio de tous les voilà vous me
demandez souvent comment je fais le
beagle vous voulez voir du behind the
thin un petit peu des tournages qu'on
fait aujourd'hui on est avec james de la
chaîne studio sushis et il est venu
parce qu'il voulait qu'on fasse du film
de produits on va filmer et des
composants de son futur pc à 7000 euros
truc de fou donc on a installé un set up
assez sympa tu pour montrer le set-up la
regarde regarde le singe le set up
il est plutôt cool donc la cb huit ans
va absolument pas filmer bébé 8 mai
c'était pour le test et on va vous
montrer un petit peu comment on va faire
tout ça et salut à tous les amis c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravi et très bien entouré
de vous accueillir
encore une fois sur cette chaîne pour
une nouvelle vidéo vers si vous aimez la
vidéo si vous aimez le montage si vous
aimez matos les caméras tout ça vous
pouvez penser à vous abonner en cliquant
sur le petit bouton qui situe juste en
dessous activer la clause tout ça parce
que sur cette chaîne y aura plein de
choses qui vont très probablement vous
plaire hélas birol
juste un petit peu de banderoles pour
vous mettre en appétit
[Musique]
amar
mais alors qu'une astuce pour filmer des
produits sur une table comme ça et faire
un beau birol c'est l'éclairage par
dessus sur ce genre de produit c'est
hyper flatteur et ça rend vraiment
encore mieux plutôt que de faire un
éclairage de trois quarts ou un
éclairage de face
si vous avez la possibilité ici on en
insistant de la piste n pour suspendre
la future en hauteur si vous avez la
possibilité même ne serait-ce que
d'accrocher ou de bidouiller un truc
avec un trépied pour éclairer de dessus
n'hésitez pas ça va rendre de suite
beaucoup beaucoup mieux
[Musique]
e
alors danseurs de tournage il ya des
trucs comme ces petites lampes là comme
ça que ces petites led d'appoint c'est
une moman c'est un truc qui coûte pas
très cher et qui qui éclaire bien
toujours utile parce que là on avait un
petit problème d'un angle en fête et de
réflexion on a rajouté un tout petit peu
de lights pour éclairer le processeur là
pour le coup ne casse pas le truc james
qui va tout péter
tu va tout péter je suis sûr que tu vas
tout péter donc voilà ça c'est des
petits accessoires je vous mets le lien
description ça être toujours pour ce
genre de bien au delà d'avoir une petite
d'un petit éclairage d'appoint ou si en
plus du gros éclairage là qu'on a ici le
stream dec
je n'ai aucune idée de ce à quoi ça sert
puisque je ne trime pas moi je suis
vieux un chien un vieux de la vie si
vous savez ce que c'est un stream dec ce
que james a pas voulu me le dire on me
le dit dans les commentaires soyez sympa
vous au moins deux refus me dire je m'en
vais te tuer a expliqué quand même parce
que c'était le string beck le sort
[Musique]
oh
là on a terminé pour les plans macro
avec le loud donc on va faire d'autres
plans avec des objectifs plus classiques
et des plans un peu moins exotique on va
dire on va je sais pas encore si on va
encore utilisé slider ou pas ou si on va
faire ça aux stabilisateurs comme on est
dans un petit espace est que déjà la
lumière prend beaucoup d'espacé je pense
qu'on va plutôt faire ça au slider voire
même à la main 1 pourquoi pas soyons
fous à la main ça peut marcher aussi
alors du coup pour la suite on est resté
sur le slider d'ailleurs ce slider je
vous mets le lien en descriptions il est
vraiment pas cher et il fonctionne hyper
bien on est passé sur le cameroun 28,75
pour avoir des plantes plus serré on n'a
pas besoin forcément d'avoir de grandes
ouvertures pour filmer les produits
parce que justement on aura trop de fou
comme on va faire un petit peu d'effets
de perspectives ça sert à rien d'ouvrir
au maximum genre 18.4 ça sert
strictement à rien produit produit
l'idée c'est qu'on voit le produit en
entier donc essayez plutôt de booster la
lumière plutôt que d'ouvrir trop le
diaphragme parce qu'on verra tout
simplement pas bien le produit et si
vous voulez voir tout les spex du pc si
vous voulez voir encore plus de bérulle
n'hésitez pas à aller faire un tour sur
la chaîne de james parce qu'ils seront
une vidéo exactement en même temps
quasiment en même temps avec d'autres
extraits de ce tournage avec plein
d'infos sur ce pc de ouf qui sera sa
station de montage donc aller faire un
petit tour sur sa chaîne ça lui fera
plaisir et en plus ça vaut le coup ah
oui ça peut paraître aussi un petit peu
évident mais on va préférer utiliser le
focus manuel plutôt que l'autofocus
parce qu'on reste de galérer en fonction
des angles en fonction du du produit la
l'idéal - j'ai mis à 5,6 et focus money
james ce tournage de birol qu'est ce que
t'en as pensé je suis content d'avoir
fait le déplacement tu vois c'est vrai
parce que moi j'aurais pas fait aussi
bien
vraiment chapeau françois explique pas
encore envie rôle et voilà les amis
j'espère que cette vidéo ben un petit
peu inhabituel vous aura plus que vous
aurez appris des trucs pour filmer des
dépôts produits faire du joli birol
d'ailleurs si cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre le traditionnel
coup de blaster n'y a pas que les
basterds dit non
exploser le traditionnel coup le placer
sur le pouce en l'air qui se situe juste
en dessous de cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner si c'est pas déjà fait
laisser des commentaires nike et toussa
toussa
puis moi comme d'habitude en attendant
je vous dis rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
et pour toi qui restait encore une fois
jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo mais tu as
bien fait de rester jusqu'à la fin de la
vidéo parce que la partie jeux films
n'est pas filmé avec ma caméra habituel
mais avec une autre caméra et pour
savoir de quelle caméra il s'agit il
faudra juste revenir à la prochaine
vidéo puisque j'en parlerai en vidéo
dans la prochaine vidéo voilà